um it's just the completion rate is
okay um
strategy committee
call for any apologies first
[Music]
against the right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
in the data with lots of commentary and
various
discussions at the moment so welcome to
the
to the council on the first council of
our first meeting here so
you'll sack up the words
[Music]
[Music]
and some of that didn't come to fruition
this year they will
excuse otherwise yeah okay
um just moving to our first agenda item
um it's the court cbd the amenity
[Music]
received an um from our chief executive
institute
in public
you know liking uh in cbd and main
street
we built a really strong team consistent
and we identified the problems
[Music]
and there are some improvements
lighting is out of service there is
no discussion around who is responsible
of course
we expect you
there are some locations which really
can add value to
our
some of them
[Music]
is
uh
they
uh
[Music]
[Music]
um
okay
most council would
[Music]
[Music]
with other commitments that you may have
and as we always do there's loads of
plan
whether it's year one or further
deadline
but at least it's a starting point
acknowledge the frustrations of council
davis who is asked about three times at
this
project get movement so it does have
official recognition at least entirely
amongst the staff
and the team and i think you'll find
some definition in time for
if you wish
um
[Music]
uh
[Music]
and business area uh it took a
failure and then you got some idea along
with the original idea to develop a
delivery project they took advice
fortunately
you know strategy but the idea is to
have some trials
to facilitate you know further
development
you know they wanted to
you know increase improve their
liveability or
[Music]
[Music]
and of course you know
low maintenance option in future for
example if we reduce the
speed of the cars speed limit
then we will have less you know
maintenance
you know services
there are some uh ideas but that means
the main aspect of this project is to be
community projects
we started working with community we
organized
three large workshops and some other
workshops
individual community groups
there was a huge
action from the community we got
enthusiastic people supporting
the project ideas
those
[Music]
and everything is written then
we continue discussion with sata
the hard work because it's not like
other projects going to designers
providing some
scope and implementing everything should
be
developed on community desires
criteria we are working on the details
and the engaged
specialists also to help us to see how
we can
progress in the meantime we have a focus
community group
who are supporting us through the
process the we could summarize the
community and goods in sixth category
uh the major one of the major issues
is around the schools and congestion in
southern states
visitors
which we can somehow connect this
project to some space
to the marketing requirements
more sitting facilities more pedestrian
facilities
once we analyzed them we got some
options and solutions we went back to
the community game
as i said this is community project and
we will
see what we changed because the initial
discussion was quite generic
or something should be changed
um
[Music]
thank you mr chairman and i'd just like
to congratulate you both on the
report and it's quite in-depth and
really good to see where we're going
you've obviously got a great plan
and one of my questions was when we do
get the trials i'm going to go back to
the community
you've just answered that machine so
thank you i think it's really good that
we're doing
all this community consultation and
working with reference group
so that would be my question the
reference group will
also be listened to and worked with
for the trials
um
[Music]
we've talked about the ncta are pushing
for hard change
this was trying to be a bit more uh
trying to recognize
the tolerance of our community and so
that
negotiations or discussions at the
moment
[Music]
is
thank you
[Music]
just a question around i know
[Music]
um
so what happens if we didn't quite hit
the timelines
does that put money in jupiter
there is um
services diversity spent on this stage
we put it
so the connectivity with nzta through
this project
how active is that
it's a different process essentially in
the same way
business case supplements aren't
approved
[Music]
um
is a very good question and there's no
certainty of
project outcomes because it is very
serious to push us
to implement something to do something
if we delay
the budget can be easily
i believe that million dollars is for
trials
and after the trials are completed if
there's some of the projects that want
to go
that you would like to go ahead how is
that going to be funded
is that through ncta are they going to
fund these projects or is it
a council
through the project we have a budget
every year
a few years with the advanced fund when
we've gone from ncta
59 we're able to
launch that's a low cost uh activity
plus
some of the things that we put in place
the trials will
um
um
[Music]
thank you mr chairman um i'm just
thinking you know given that we're only
a few weeks out from christmas
i'm sort of hoping that there'll be
nothing sort of started for the cbd
over that time
[Music]
um
[Music]
shopkeepers won't be thrilled if we've
got things going on in your place so
yeah but i'm sure
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
the community
here having seen the workshops through
the various
matters that have occurred around town
as the council has been indicated
anything that happens
uh when we do repeat these things there
is
that come back and conversations and
counselors will hear about
various different issues the one
question i was going to ask is
with anything that's ongoing we can
obviously still
put that information into you to be
included as this process goes
whether someone spots a proper
problematic situation or
maintenance development we obviously
still put that process through you that
can be included with us
[Music]
to feedback i also have presents out
and we're putting against installations
when it comes to
opportunity
i have um to um
let's conclude